ROMAN NURIK: Hello again,
and welcome to
Android Design in Action.
I'm Roman Nurik.
ADAM KOCH: Adam Koch.
NICK BUTCHER: And
Nick Butcher.
ROMAN NURIK: And today we're
going to talk about a sleep
monitor app and backward
compatibility.
We have a lot of content to get
through today, so we're
just going to get started
with sleep monitors.
So the app that we decided
to look at today
was Sleep as Android.
It's called Sleep as Android.
This is one of the apps that was
reviewed on the App Clinic
last Friday by Reto Meier.
And Nick took a look at this
app in much detail.
And Nick, do you want
to jump into your
thoughts on Sleep as Android?
NICK BUTCHER: Sure.
So Sleep as Android is an
application that monitors your
sleep and lets you set an alarm,
so it will wake you up
at an opportune time when you're
in a very kind of light
sleep cycle.
It's a very detailed app.
If you take a look at it,
it offers a whole ton of
functionality and configuration
options.
And you can see that the author
is very responsive to
the community.
He's put out something like 15
updates in the last couple of
months alone, which is very,
very responsive.
From a visual point of view,
they have made some effort to
get towards the Holo
design guidelines.
But my overall feeling of the
application was that while
it's very, very functional and
powerful, I found it kind of
hard to get into and understand
how to operate and
to prioritize what tasks I
should be doing first and what
information was important.
So if we take a look at
the application here--
this is the first screen you
see when you start the app.
This is where you can create
different alarms, as well as
there's a prompt to unlock.
And some of the key
functionality on this screen
is down there on the bottom
left, kind of like a
split-action bar, but kind
of not a split-action
bar at the same time.
And you can see some of the
functionality there is to add
a new alarm, start the actual
sleep-tracking mode, to see
some statistics of your previous
night's sleep.
So, since we're short for time,
should we go straight
into the redesign and see
what we cooked up?
So here, you can see
we've done--
it's not a huge departure, but
we tried to apply some of the
Holo look and feel to
the application.
So straight off there's a
standard action bar giving
that that sense of where you
are, and a common place to
look for some of the actions.
I felt like we had to reorganize
some of the
functionality a little bit,
because this main screen,
while it offered the alarms,
there's a lot of functionality
kind of hanging off sub-screens,
as well.
And I felt like this app has
two main purposes, which is
setting alarms for waking up
at the right time, and for
monitoring your sleep
and seeing how that
sleep pattern is going.
So I wanted to float those
right up as your primary
options into these two main
tabs, here, these Alarms and
Stats tabs.
As you can see, we've also
really, really emphasized the
Track Sleep button.
So instead of just a little
button at the bottom with
equal, fair weighting toward
the other options, it's now
this gigantic purple button.
And finally, a little note on
the coloring and the palette.
I found some of the green
highlights to be grabbing your
focus, saying, look at me,
I'm a divider, which felt
slightly off to me.
So we readdressed the palette
a little bit here.
It's taking quite a lot of
cues from the stock alarm
clock in the latest version of
Android for two reasons.
Firstly, I like it.
I think it's a that beautiful
app-- might be controversial,
not everyone thinks so.
But also, it is offering
slightly similarly
functionality, so it's
helping to bootstrap
these as mental model.
A lot of the user interface
elements we've used look the
same as from the stock
alarm clock app.
So hopefully it can get started
with this application
a bit quicker.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
One thing I wanted to mention
about the color scheme, the
switch from these neon green
to a neon violet.
I guess it's the violet that's
in the Android Design official
color palette.
I think that it's just a little
less in your face.
It's still very much
an accent color.
It's not like a dull gray
or a dull blue,
where it's more muted.
But it's a little easier
on the eyes.
And I think you can even
probably go even one shade
darker, if you want.
On some devices, it
may be too bright.
But I think it's just much
easier to look at the screen
and not be overwhelmed
immediately.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
One of the thing that I wanted
to say is that this is one of
the last things you'll look
at before you go to sleep.
If you're about to go to bed,
you're going to hit Sleep.
So normally, for this kind of
app, I would immediately want
to change it to a
light palette.
For most apps I think a light
palette is generally a good
starting point.
But, for this app, because you
didn't want to have that
feeling of you're [INAUDIBLE]
and you turn your phone, and
suddenly, you're kind of
blinded by intensity.
So I tried to keep the tones
quite mute to try and ease
that kind of transition,
really.
ADAM KOCH: In terms of
navigation, I like how you've
split Stats and Alarms into the
top-level tabs there, and
removing it from the faux
split-action bar that was in
the previous version, leaving
the two main actions that are
visible there-- the Track
Sleep and the Add.
NICK BUTCHER: I found a point
on the before shot.
You can see there's a little
bug droid figure
in the bottom corner.
And his state changes depending
on how close it is
to you having to go to bed.
So right now, it's the daytime,
and he's got a
[INAUDIBLE] in front
of him or whatever.
But as he gets close to night,
he starts brushing his
teeth and so on.
And while I think that's
useful and fun--
I do really like that--
I do find sometimes including
a bug droid in your
application or even Android or
Droid in the name of the
application is kind of
lazy and amateurish.
It doesn't really shout, this
is a fully professional
application.
I've thought through
the interaction.
So I tried to incorporate the
same elements using Same
Difference.
So if you can see on the
aftershot, very subtly,
there's a number of sleepy Z's
in the background to the
application.
The idea here being as you get
closer to bedtime, more of
them start coming out from the
Track Sleep button or you
could have them subtly
animate in some ways.
It's very, very subtle here, but
it's trying to convey the
same kind of information, but in
a slightly more subtle way.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
And we also did a job on
changing the icons.
So we shifted the icon from
being a sleeping, cute bug
droid to something
very generic.
This is just a very generic
icon, but, again, something
that is a little more
recognizable and something
unique to the app.
NICK BUTCHER: Cool.
[INAUDIBLE].
ROMAN NURIK: Should we move
on to the next screen?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
All righty.
So next up.
The next one of the major
functions I thought this app
does is give you lots of
information about how you have
been sleeping, almost too
much information.
So if we touch the graph, like
on the bottom left, you get to
the subsequent screen here with
a number of options here.
So we've picked out the Stat
screen here, which can have a
very, very long table.
And this is just and a small
sampling of information,
because I hadn't been running
the app for very long.
If you look at the developer's
screenshots on the place
though, you can see this
can be a massive table.
And while it gives you some
average stats, it's summed up
over all time.
Now, I tried to readdress this
and think, what do I really
care about?
I probably only care about the
last week's stats, like
anything that's older than that
probably doesn't really
have much bearing on how I feel
my sleep has been going.
What happened two months
ago isn't really
relevant any longer.
So what I've done with this
screen is I've tried to
provide these summary stats.
So the most important thing to
me is a summary of this week,
how have I been doing for the
last, say, seven days or
whenever the start of the week
in your calendar starts from.
And so we've pulled out some
summary statistics, and those
are big and bold.
And it uses color to signify
whether you are close to your
target average length of sleep
per night or whether you're
building up a sleep debt.
So here, we can see we're using
orange for OK-ish, blue
for yeah, you're doing well, or
red for warning, you're not
getting enough sleep.
So instantly, when I look at
this, I get this quick,
scannable screen which tells
me what's going on.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
You can see that on Tuesday,
you, for some reason, didn't
sleep very well.
Maybe you were out on the town
the night before, or
something like that.
NICK BUTCHER: Too
many Christmas
parties at the moment.
So, we've consciously demoted
a lot of information.
So if you look at the before,
there's other tabs for noise
and graphs, as well as some kind
of store, as well, which
didn't seem to be worthy
of being a
top-level information item.
It was kind of like adding
noise, and making it harder
for me to realize what
was really important.
So we've really simplified it
down to these few items, and
we let you roll the whole week
up and down, if you want to
turn it into a summary or drill
down into each one.
We still think this
information's interesting, for
those people who
want it though.
So the idea here is that you can
tap on each of the days.
You can then go forward into a
subsequent screen, which is
going to give you details about
that one night's sleep
that you've tracked.
ROMAN NURIK: Cool.
NICK BUTCHER: So here, on the
next slide, instead of having
this whole roll of graphs--
that kind of view of all the
different days as a graph
didn't really tell me much.
I didn't find that
very glanceable.
You couldn't really look at it
and say, oh, that was a good
night, oh, that was
a bad night.
But the graphs themselves
are quite cool.
So we demoted them down
to a detail screen.
So if you touched each of the
line items from the previous
screen, you get through to sleep
details that will tell
you how long you actually slept
for, how long of that
was in deep sleep, what
percentage, and give you that
really nice graph showing
you exactly what
the night was like.
That's where there's
a [INAUDIBLE]
information can capture when
you record your sleep--
like a rating or a comment on
how good a night it was.
So these are really details
that truly change the
information hierarchy and
can put these down to
a subsequent screen.
[INAUDIBLE].
ROMAN NURIK: I think it was
just a great job, just
splitting up a very, very
complex screen-- a complex
screen that has good
data, but it's just
not as easy to consume.
And showing you something that's
letting you really look
at the content, or one specific
piece of content, the
specific day, and seeing
all the details on it.
I think it's just a good
combination of different types
of pieces of the content, like
a graph, some averages, some
data like that.
Potentially allowing the user to
provide a comment, or even
providing a recommendation.
Like maybe you should wear
something or sleep stiller.
Who knows?
I know nothing about sleeping
medication or
anything like that.
But giving the user all these
different types of components
to their one night of sleep is
a really interesting and
unique way to present that.
ADAM KOCH: Yeah.
Personally, I really like the
typography that you've used
here, Nick, on both this screen
and the other screen.
It just really brings out the
important information, and
plus the coloring
really helps.
It helps you glance at it
and see what's going on.
NICK BUTCHER: Cool.
And there's one final redesign
idea we had for this
application.
And that's to take advantage
of a cool new feature in
Android 4.2 called Daydreams.
So for those of you who might
not be aware, Daydreams is
like a screensaver
functionality.
So you can set up a Daydream to
say that when my device is
docked or charging, kick
over into this--
kind of like a screensaver.
So what I thought would be
really, really cool is rather
than having to manually go into
the application and start
it to track you sleeping,
it would be awesome if--
just the fact that, I guess,
most people like me probably
plug their phone in at night
so it's charging overnight.
So just doing that is enough
to say kick off a Daydream,
which will then start
tracking your sleep.
I imagine you'd probably put
some logic in there if it's in
the middle of the day, or
something like this.
You wouldn't actually
kick off Daydream.
But just the act of plugging in
the device and putting it
down on your bed could then kick
off the functionality.
So I really find it's a bit of
a burden on the user to have
to go into this application
every night and
remember to do it.
Hit the Start button,
hit the Stop button.
Remember to do that
in the morning.
So anything you can do to
automate that process I think
is going to make the
user more regular.
They're going to keep on using
it and see the value of their
application.
So I thought a Daydream might
be a cool way to do that.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
It's just another way to step
up the level of, or the
feeling of, magic in this
app, where, if you can
automatically track these
things, then do it.
So before 9:00 PM, 10:00 PM,
if it turns on, or if your
phone goes idle, maybe you
just show a clock.
It's fairly easy to just create
a simple clock Daydream
that just shows the current
time and the current date.
But then after a certain point,
it kicks into kind of
tracking mode and
shows the clock.
And maybe this is a way to play
like soothing sounds in
the background or something,
as you're sleeping.
So since this app is already
doing all this data capture,
maybe it can use that
intelligently to even improve
your sleep as you're sleeping,
maybe by playing sounds or
something like that.
So, lots of ideas here.
I think the Daydream idea
is really good, here.
Nick.
ADAM KOCH: Yeah.
And, of course, you
can interact with
Daydreams, as well.
So you could still have
something that you could touch
and resize, or potentially
graphs during the day that you
could look at or something
like that.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
So overall, a really nice app
with lots and lots of
functionality.
I hope the developer likes some
of the ideas we've thrown
around there and perhaps
runs with them.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
And if you're the developer of
this app and you're watching,
feel free to let us know what
you think on Google+ or even
email or whatever.
But we're definitely looking
forward to talking to you if
you have any questions or if
you want some of the ideas.
Or even some of the source.psd
files, or anything that.
If we ever review your app or
take a look at your app and we
do a mock up, if you want to
sources, they're are always
available--
no licensing issues.
We'll just hand them
over to you.
NICK BUTCHER: And we
do it with love.
I saw some comments for our past
redesign of [INAUDIBLE]
saying, is that a slap-down
from Google having them to
redesign your app?
That's not what this
show is about.
This is about what
it could be.
We'd love to work with you to
help you get the best Android
design that you can.
ROMAN NURIK: Yep.
And almost all the apps we
review, they're awesome apps.
They're really just good.
They're fulfilling their
functions really well.
NICK BUTCHER: OK.
We need to move on.
ROMAN NURIK: Yes, we should.
ADAM KOCH: [INAUDIBLE].
ROMAN NURIK: So we've
got 15 minutes left.
We need to fly through backward
compatibility.
So we have a lot of slides on
backward compatibility--
fortunately, a lot of them
are screenshots.
But let's get started.
So before we talk about our
strategies and tips for
backward compatibility, and
specifically for designing for
backward compatibility, not so
much for developing for that.
We have lots and lots of
training sessions and all that
for developers, but
this is really
more targeted at designers.
Before we share some of our own
tips here, I'd definitely
make sure that you guys, you
designers out there, are
looking at the design guidelines
for compatibility.
The guideline's page for
compatibility is fairly short.
It only talks about a few
important things.
Some of the things include the
Legacy menu button, how Action
Overflow behaves across
different devices.
So it's definitely stuff that
you should be aware of before
jumping into mockups
or anything.
NICK BUTCHER: Just pause
this video right
now and go read it.
We'll wait.
And we're back.
ADAM KOCH: Let's move on.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
We do have a lot to cover.
So backward compatibility.
The way we view backward
compatibility is that for each
screen in your app-- and you
could extend this to your
entire app or just an
individual widget--
for each screen, visual styling
and the behavior,
basically visual and interaction
design, can
operate along a spectrum of how
close it is to the primary
version of the app.
So for example, and if I have an
app design for Android 4.0
and above, and I have Holo
elements in there, on earlier
versions, on Android 2.3,
Gingerbread, Froyo, whatever,
you can make a choice of either
taking that Holo design
or your completely
custom design and
using it on that device.
Or you can kind of
say whatever the
device default is--
for example, for check boxes
on Gingerbread, they were
green instead of blue--
in some devices back
then, it was like
blue, red or whatever.
You can make the choice that I
should use a device default,
or you could just choose
something in the middle.
So usually it's a little harder
to make everything Holo
back to Gingerbread and Froyo.
It's very, very easy
for developers to
use the device defaults.
And then this hybrid is
somewhere in the middle.
So the hybrid solution--
you have to be kind of
careful about it.
It can still really work, and
we'll show you guys in the
screenshots coming up that
hybrid UIs, where some
components are Holo and some
components are using the
device default styling,
they can work.
So we'll show a couple
of examples of those.
But this is really how we see
the way you decide on a
backward compatibility
strategy.
You kind of pick somewhere
along the spectrum.
And depending on where you
choose, you need to work with
your developers on this.
But depending on where you
choose, that will change the
amount of effort involved for
developers, and certainly it
will change the final outcome.
But just be aware that these are
the different options, and
there's really no correct
choice, I'd say.
Like I said before, you can do
it correctly, you can do it
right using any one of these
different options.
It's really up to you to make
sure that it just works well.
ADAM KOCH: Yeah.
It's really just a
trade-off between
these different options.
Like there's more effort
involved on the left side of
the spectrum, but you'll have
a more consistent look.
On the right side, it can still
work, as we'll show you
in the screenshots shortly.
NICK BUTCHER: A bit
more effort.
There's some tools out
there to help.
ROMAN NURIK: Absolutely.
And we'll talk about the tools
out there that are more
relevant to the developers
and designers, but still,
definitely, there is stuff
out there to help.
So having said that, Holo--
a lot of people ask
us-- is Holo for
Android 4.0 and above?
In the end, should I even try
to use Holo in earlier
versions of the platform?
And our answer is yes.
Holo is not designed just for
the latest devices out there.
Holo is really designed for all
people, for all humans.
It's really a design language
for human-computer
interaction, not just
human-Android 4.0 Plus
interaction.
It can work everywhere.
Obviously, it takes some effort
to make it work, but
again, as a designer, you to
think of it less as the
styling of Android 4.0,
and really as
the identity of Android.
So that's an important
point to make.
Another is that the core
experience across all
platforms should really
be consistent.
You shouldn't really have to
design an entirely separate
app for Gingerbread and for
Ice Cream Sandwich.
So things like the action bar,
those should be visible and
persistent across all devices.
You shouldn't switch into a
completely different UI on
earlier versions just
because there's no
built-in framework component.
And, again, we'll
talk about that.
So things like layouts, the core
layouts, the navigation--
like swiping between tabs--
and the core interactions--
like the basic way you choose
a contact, for example.
Those should really behave
the same across
different OS versions.
And I think that for design--
and the last point is really
more about developers--
but be opportunistic.
Beyond the core experience, the
core navigation, really,
the core feel of the app, like
the individual check boxes,
and the spinners, and
things like that, be
opportunistic about it.
Make sure that nothing looks
really bad, obviously, but be
opportunistic.
And don't put yourself in a
position where you must have
everything pixel-perfect,
because that's
just a losing battle.
It's going to take too much
time, and you're going to lose
focus from what's really
important, and that is the
core experience of the app.
So before we go on, any
other points, guys?
About these three?
NICK BUTCHER: Nope.
ADAM KOCH: Let's go.
ROMAN NURIK: Solid.
Let's go.
ADAM KOCH: Let's do it.
ROMAN NURIK: Another thing to
mention-- this is more on the
tactical side.
So one of the big differences,
and you'll see this in
screenshots, between Android 4.0
and Android 2.3 and such
is the topography,
is the font.
So Roboto is the default on
Android 4.0 and higher, and
Droid Sans was the default
everywhere else.
So this is one area where you
really shouldn't try to just
take Roboto and use it
everywhere on Android 2.3.
The reason being that users
are really accustomed to
seeing-- like their eyes almost
expect to read text in
a certain way on their device,
and so you should really just
use the system default font.
The good thing is that for
designers, when you're
planning out the widths of your
elements and things, you
have to think, obviously, how
many characters will fit in
this line or in this
UI widget.
And the good thing is that
Roboto and Droid Sans are
metrics-compatible, meaning
that if you take the same
piece of text in Roboto and
Droid Sans on an Android 2.3
device and an Android 4.0
device, you'll notice that
they're pretty much
the same width.
So what's more important here
is things like translations,
where, for example, the German
version or the German strings
for something will cause
things to be
really, really wide.
That's more important to think
about than just saying, oh, I
need to choose the
right font here.
So be more aware of that than
just the difference between
Droid Sans and Roboto in
English, for example.
And then also--
this is, again, more
for tactics--
but in your process, it's really
important for designers
to participate in the
device-testing process.
So usually, you'll have a QA
team or maybe a developer that
has a whole bunch of devices,
and they're kind of testing
the APKs on all those devices.
Designers should really
participate, because sometimes
designers in a team are
some of the most
visually sensitive folks.
So they'll be able to pick out
what the little quirks are.
So, as a designer, you should
try to introduce yourself into
the QA process.
Not, obviously, full-time, but
spend some time making sure
that you're testing the output
on earlier versions of the
platform as well different
devices, so you just get a
feel for what it looks like.
NICK BUTCHER: And there's
a bunch of continuous
integration tools that test your
app on different versions
and will produce screenshots.
And you can take a look at the
screenshot generated on older
or smaller devices [INAUDIBLE],
which will help
you [INAUDIBLE].
ROMAN NURIK: And this is
something that, Nick, you
alluded to earlier, but if a
developer comes to you as a
designer and says, we can't do
this specific UI because it's
only available on Honeycomb
and above or
Android 4.0 and above.
That's not always a great
excuse, because there are
great libraries out there that
solve this for them.
So you don't have to think that,
oh, I need to design an
app with an action bar and an
app without an action bar, and
an app with all Holo components,
and an app with
zero Holo components, because
it's just not available.
There are lots of libraries out
there that will help you.
Here are just a few.
So ActionBarSherlock, I'm
sure a lot of you
are familiar with.
That, basically, is almost a
100% backport of the action
bar to previous versions
of the platform.
HoloEverywhere actually gives
you a lot of the standard
widget styling, like spinners
and text fields and such.
And, actually, they do a lot
more, like calendars, calendar
view, and things like that.
The give you a lot.
This library gives you a lot
of stuff that you can just
backport to earlier versions.
So if a developer comes to you
and says, I absolutely cannot
use the action bar because it's
not available on earlier
versions of the platform,
fight that.
Tell them that you do have tools
available to you, and
maybe that's not the greatest
reason for not doing it.
Before we move into the
screenshots, any extra
thoughts, parting wisdom for
backward compatibility
strategies?
NICK BUTCHER: Holo
all the things.
ADAM KOCH: Holo everything.
ROMAN NURIK: Holo
all the things.
But it's really up
to you, right?
As a designer, you should be
aware of the different types
of devices out there, be aware
of the tools that developers
have to them, and make the right
decision for your app.
NICK BUTCHER: More seriously,
I'd say that if you had
infinite resources, you'd
probably end up writing a
version of your app which
[INAUDIBLE] write a home in
Ice Cream Sandwich, write a home
on Gingerbread, write a
home on Froyo.
But given not everyone has the
resources to do that, you want
to put most of your effort into
skating where the puck's
going, and designing for Holo
and then, like Roman says, be
opportunistic about backporting
the finer pixel
control stuff, where you
have the capacity.
ROMAN NURIK: All right.
So in the interest of time,
since I think our producer
actually has to run in about
five minutes or so.
So let's fly through
some screenshots.
So all these screenshots are
going to be apps that we feel
do the right thing, and you're
going to see that it's a
combination of that universal
Holo everywhere, kind of a
pure, device default, and
somewhere in the middle.
So this is tasks-free.
This is both the interactions
and visuals on Gingerbread and
Jelly Bean, and you'll see
that throughout all these
screenshots.
So this is just their
edit screen.
You'll notice that they have
Holo styling everywhere.
This is the same, tasks-free.
And all these slides will
be available after.
And, by the way, guys,
feel free to jump
in as you see fit.
But this is all just, again,
another example of apps that
have a pure universal
look and feel here.
This is Pattern, another app
that is a really good example
of how to do things almost
perfectly replicated across
Gingerbread and Jelly Bean.
And this is the first example
you see where
there's hybrid styling.
So the Play Store on Gingerbread
uses kind of the
standard text fields and a
custom button style, and on
ICS and above, they use
the Holo text field
styling and the Holo--
well, actually, I guess it's
also a custom button.
But, again.
It works really well
in both cases.
There's no obvious mismatch
of components here.
This is one minor case I wanted
to point out, where
almost everything here in Series
Guide in Holo, except
for the little stars.
And so these stars, here, in
Gingerbread are green, on ICS,
they're blue.
And, really, again, it doesn't
really detract from the
experience that it's sharing
some styling, and that it's
using what the device
has as a default.
This is an example
of the I/O App.
This is just one minor
screen, where
there's a mix of styling.
This, actually, we need to
improve this for next year.
I think this could be better.
But this is an example of where
it kind of works fairly
well, but it can be improved.
NICK BUTCHER: And that's a great
example of what you're
talking about with the
typography, where the Droid
Sans looks right at home on
Gingerbread, and the Roboto
looks right at home on ICS.
ROMAN NURIK: And note all of
these use Droid Sans on
Gingerbread, and
Roboto on ICS.
Another quick example from the
Recipe Search App of text
field on the left, text
field on the right.
This is an example of using--
I think it's from How About
We, which is an
online dating site--
a mix of Holo styling for
Gingerbread and platform
default styling.
And again, it works OK.
The core feel and experience
in the app is really
maintained.
It's just this one screen has
kind of a mix of widget
styling, so I think it still
works quite well.
Another example from
How About We.
So this is another case, Search,
where by default, the
platform has this built-in
search mechanism.
So if you're using the
[? called ?] search manager,
which is kind of irrelevant
for designers, but the
platform default search looks a
certain way on Gingerbread.
And you should really try to
use that, because users are
really used to that.
Whereas in Jelly Bean, there's
another, different type a way
to do it using something called
Search View and the
action bar.
That shows that same kind
of auto-complete stuff.
So it's really very,
very similar.
The implementation's slightly
different for developers.
But, again, it's using what
users would expect--
standard platform stuff on the
left, and the standard action
bar stuff on the right.
ADAM KOCH: Another example of
Ted Search View versus old
Gingerbread styling.
ROMAN NURIK: And this is an
example of preferences, where
you generally want to use the
system defaults styling.
You don't want to have your
own custom styling there.
So, where possible, use the
standard preference, activity
preference fragment to do
all that stuff for you.
And apps like tasks which have
generally themed everything
Holo style, in the preferences,
they still fall
back on the standard--
oh, here we go.
You beat me to it.
Yeah.
The same as Ted.
ROMAN NURIK: The same as Ted.
And then this is, real
quick, to talk
about contextual actions.
Jeff, if you have to
go, by all means.
So contextual actions-- this
is something that's kind of
controversial.
Do you backport the contextual
action bar, which is kind of,
I'd say, a minor interaction.
And I think that's really
up to the developer.
If it's easy, then do it.
If not, then don't do it,
unless it's the core
experience in your app.
In this case, for Pattern, the
core mechanic here is to work
with patterns, so allowing users
to do multiple selection
on the patterns make sense here,
but certainly, I think
it's still secondary, where you
can still perform these
actions in a detail screen.
So don't feel completely
obligated to backport your
contextual action bar.
I will say the ActionBarSherlock
does this
contextual action bar
backport for you, so
something to keep in mind.
And this is an example of the
I/O App, which in which we
chose not to backport the
contextual action bar.
So here, when you long-press
something, you just get a
Context menu, which, again, is
more standard on earlier
versions of the platform.
Another screen from Pattern
where they've chosen the
device default styling
for dialogs.
And they've actually correctly
flipped the positive and
negative actions in the
dialog, which is good.
And some more from the Play
Store, and I think
that's the last one.
Yes.
OK.
ROMAN NURIK: So that was
backward compatibility.
Obviously, we can't cover
such a big topic in
such a short period.
If you guys have comments,
thoughts, feel
free to post online.
And if there's anything we
missed, we even touch on this
sometime in another episode.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
Maybe we should do
a follow-up show.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, for sure.
NICK BUTCHER: Lots
of content here.
ROMAN NURIK: Let's fly through
Design News, since we have
very little time.
First, Taylor, as always, has
been doing redesigns.
He just did a really cool
redesign on a movie ticketing
app using the Wizard Pager
example that I pushed out a
few weeks ago, which
is really cool.
And this is kind of a custom
card style, here, for the
tickets you've purchased.
It's really cool.
Obviously we recently launched
the official Android Design
Community on Google+.
Here's just a couple of examples
of post there.
If you haven't seen it yet,
I'd recommend joining--
lots of good content coming
out from there.
NICK BUTCHER: I'm loving
this community.
Really high quality of
discussion going on in there.
Good job, guys.
ROMAN NURIK: And lastly, Nick,
do you want to talk about the
response of Headache Relief
for Android slides?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
This is a really beautiful
presentation.
I highly encourage you to check
this out if you want a
good summary or take the
temperature of where
Responsive Design is on Android,
especially from a web
developer's point of view--
a really, really good
presentation.
I recommend it.
ROMAN NURIK: Awesome.
I think that's it
for the show.
Thanks to everybody
who tuned in.
We will not see you next week.
This is actually the
last show of 2012.
We will see you sometime
in 2013.
Thanks for tuning in.
I'm Roman Nurik.
ADAM KOCH: Adam Koch.
NICK BUTCHER: Bye from
Nick Butcher.
ADAM KOCH: Have a great
holidays, everyone.
ROMAN NURIK: Happy holidays.
[MUSIC PLAYING]